OF FINE-TUNING OUR BORDER
PATROL.
SPEED LENT BOTH OF YOU,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A PROBLEM THAT
WILL CONTINUE UNTIL WE DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS AND JAMES JUST
REFERRED TO CONGRESSIONAL
SOLUTIONS NECESSARY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TOM HOMAN
AND LOUISIANA RICK CONGRESSMAN
AND HOUSE WITH STEVE SCALISE.
TOM, LET'S START WITH YOU WITH
ALL YOUR EXPERTISE IN THIS
MATTER.
WHAT'S THE ONE THING THAT COULD
BE DONE RIGHT NOW TO HELP STEM
THIS TIDE OF?
>> THERE IS ACTUALLY TWO THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT READS THE
ASYLUM BALL.
AS THE ATTORNEY SAID, 88% OF
THEM PASSED THE ASYLUM INTERVIEW
BECAUSE THEY ARE COACHED ON WHAT
TO SAY.
BUT WHEN THEY GET TO COURT, THEN
THEY LOSE A CASE.
THE SECOND THING WE DO, THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO CLAIM ASYLUM AND
THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY YOU CAN
GARRETT A GUARANTEE DUE PROCESS.
KEEP THEM IN THE RESIDENTIAL
CENTER UNTIL THEY SEE THE JUDGE.
BACK IN 2014, WE KEPT THEM THERE
TO SEE THE JUDGE AND GUESS WHAT?
80%, >> CONGRESSMAN SCALISE, WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING BEFORE THIS
ELECTION.
IT COST TAXPAYERS BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO TAKE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE IN.
PUBLIC SCHOOL, HEALTH CARE, AND
IT'S A HEALTH CARE ISSUE TWO
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE HAVE COMING IN HERE.
WE HAVE DISEASES IN THIS COUNTRY
WE HAVEN'T HAD FOR DECADES.
WHAT WILL CONGRESS DO AFTER THE
MIDTERMS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE?
>> IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS YOU
WILL SEE THIS DEBATE PLAY OUT
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THAT ELECTION
IN TWO WEEKS WILL HELP DECIDE I
IT.
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PUTTING SUCH
A SHARP FOCUS ON THAT.
IT'S LIKE UP PARADE OF
ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE COACHING
THEM ALONG THE WAY SO THAT AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS MARCH,
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT COMING
OVER HERE AND LOOKING FOR JOBS
AND BY THE TIME THEY GET CLOSER,
THEY ARE BEING COACHED ABOUT HOW
TO FINALLY TRY TO GET IN HERE
LEGALLY EVEN THOUGH THIS IS NOT
WHAT THE LEGAL PROCESS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE LIKE.
WE NEED TO CHANGE THE LAW, WE'VE
HAD TWO DIFFERENT BILLS ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR.
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               E
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               H
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               V
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               E
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               H
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               D
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               A
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               T
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               L
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               V
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               T
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               S
WITHOUT ACTUALLY               O
TIGHTEN THESE LOOPHOLES UP.
>> Laura: I WOULD PULL
EVERYONE BACK FROM THE TERM
CAMPAIGNING.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, , A
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, , D
MAYBE MOST OF THEM ARE UNARMED,
OR ALL OF THEM FOR ALL WE KNOW.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE PRICING THIS
PLAY OUT, BUT THIS IS LIKE THE
PHONE IS RINGING AND NO ONE IS
HOME.
>> ERASING PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAYING, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
ALLOW THIS.
FIRST OF ALL COME ALL THE OLD
LATIN AMERICAN COUNTRIES, ALL
THOSE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
FOREIGN AID NEED TO BE ON THE
TABLE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A THREAT TO
YOUR BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
YOU ARE GETTING.
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALREADY
MADE THAT CLEAR.
THIS WILL BE IN JEOPARDY.
YOU SAW SECRETARY OF STATE
POMPEO SAYING, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO LET YOU INTO OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO TREAT THIS AS A   A A
WE HAVE TO TREAT THIS AS A   A D
INVASION BUT ALSO AS A NATION OF
LAWS.
JUST PLAY BY THE RULES.
THERE ARE RULES THAT YOU CAN
PLAY BY BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO
GAIN THE SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THESE LAWS HAVE TO BE CHANGED,
AND THERE WILL BE AN ELECTION IN
JUST TWO WEEKS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT --
PELOSI WANTS OPEN BORDERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE A GREAT
JOB OF MAKING THIS AN ELECTION
ISSUE BECAUSE A COUNTRY WILL
ULTIMATELY DECIDE.
NATIONAL SECURITY OPEN BORDERS,
I'M FOR IT, NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> THE GROUPS THAT ARE
FACILITATING THIS, THEY ARE
COCONSPIRATORS.
>> WHAT THEY DESCRIBE IS
ABSOLUTELY AIDING AND ABETTING
AND HELPING PEOPLE.
THAT'S A VIOLATION OF
UNITED STATES CODE 1324 WHICH IS
A FELONY.
SO THEY NEED TO WORK WITH THE